last night as news emerged of president
Trump's missile strike against the
Syrian Air Field sort of quickly began
examining Trump's old tweets from 2013
many of which opposed the possibility of
action in Syria by Barack Obama he
tweeted what will we get for bombing
Syria besides more debt and a possible
long-term conflict Obama needs
congressional approval he also tweeted
the president must get congressional
approval before attacking Syria big
mistake if he does not and then there
was the reexamination of Senator Ted
Cruz's position on American involvement
in the Syrian conflict in 2013 crew said
that Assad's chemical weapons use was
quote not a direct threat to US national
security and added in such behavior was
quote well outside the traditional scope
of US military action now Cruz's silent
on Trump's airstrikes adding quote I
look forward to our commander-in-chief
making the case to Congress and the
American people in 2013 I was one of the
people who opposed Obama's pre stated
pinpricks strike I tweeted Hugh Hewitt
lobbing missiles into Syria without
decapitating the regime strengthens
mostest that both Assad and the mullahs
I also wrote in a column around that
time that Obama's strategy was destined
to fail because he had no credibility to
uphold he was negotiating a deal with
the Syrian sponsor state Iran he was
undermining American allies all over the
region he was making the only standard
for intervention use of chemical weapons
while ignoring all of us odds other war
atrocities so what's changed between
2013 and now three things first Trump
can re-establish American credibility
Obama had already blown American
credibility out of the water for four
years by the time Assad gassed his own
people it was obvious to everybody
Democrats and Republicans that not only
then Obama lack a plan in Syria he was
looking to launch a few missiles to
silence criticisms of his pathetic
foreign policy as I tweeted then hitting
a few donkeys in the rear in Syria
wouldn't do anything but make Assad look
stronger and the United States weaker
the same is not true of Trump he's a
brand new president a man of mystery on
foreign policy a coherent plan of action
following a strong immediate response to
a chemical attack can help reshape the
map in different ways than Obama could
in 2013 second the russian-iranian axis
is now operated in Syria after Obama
hands it over control of Syria to Russia
in 2013 I wrote this quote thanks to
President Obama's statements in August
2012 regarding a Syrian redline on
chemical weapons use in Syria the United
States was faced with three choices in
Syria to pose Assad do nothing in order
to prevent al Qaeda from taking over the
country or as John Kerry advocated push
for an unbelief
ibly small action in order to reinforce
America's credibility the third option
was probably the worst but in a truly
awe-inspiring display of his
foreign-policy genius Obama has found a
fourth option appeasement complete with
international weapons inspections it
rejected just a week ago in 2013 our
geopolitical interests in Syria were
significantly less important than they
are now thanks to Russia's aggressively
reshaping of the Middle East Obama
handed over power to Russia in Syria
thereby helping complete an Iranian
Russian access that now spans from Iran
to Lebanon and then backed around
through his idiotic and evil nuclear
deal that made around a regional power
again all of that is creating a safe
haven and bases strength iranian-backed
terrorist strengthening Putin's hand as
an expansionist dictator and even
creating an incentive for countries to
oppose around in Russia to covertly
support Isis blunting Russia's ambitions
in Syria without drawing us into a war
with them is it worthwhile goal third
the map does not look like it did in
2013 here's the graphic of control of
Syria in 2013 you can see those blue
dots up in the top those are the Kurds
then you see the red dots let's feed the
opposition and the black dots are the
government now here's a map from March
2017 okay you can see the black there is
Isis the red is the Syrian government
and the yellow is the Kurds note the
geographic divides note also the new
clarity about the identities of some of
us odds rivals in that first map you
didn't know who his rivals were here you
know a lot of myrrh Isis this means that
America's strategic goals have changed
now it's no longer about supposing Assad
per se which was always a questionable
goal given his terrorist rivals America
has no interest in intervening in the
middle of the Syrians of war we do have
interests regarding Assads dominance and
fighting Isis Russia and Assad are not
interested in fighting Isis that was
always a fantasy of pro-russian
isolationists our best policy at this
point is to contain the region without
serious intervention kill as many Isis
members as possible along with friendly
countries and to deter major human
rights violations it's possible if
possible welham bulging the Kurds in
that yellow northern region that's why
Trump's first strike matters but it
won't matter unless he has some sort of
strategy to back it up if he doesn't it
will be precisely the same as Obama's
proposed pinprick strike and will have
been a counterproductive rather than a
first blow toward restoring American
interests on the world stage I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
alrighty so obviously ton of news to get
to kneel or search has now been
confirmed he is now going to be on the
Supreme Court good for Senate Majority
Mitch McConnell Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell I didn't think he was actually
going to do it he did invoke the nuclear
option did what he was supposed to do
good for him we also get to a full
analysis of what is happening in Syria
is it good is it bad or are we undecided
but first I want to say thank you to our
advertisers over a bowl and branch so
and somebody who is a really light
sleeper a really poor sleeper there's
nothing that I appreciate more than the
bull and branch sheets that are on my
bed vol l and branch com these are the
most comfortable sheets I have ever
owned i bought them I think three
separate sheets sets from bowl and
branch because they are so comfortable
they're organic cotton but you know they
are all I can tell you I don't know much
about sheets I don't know much about
thread count what I do know is what
feels good and what breeds at night and
what is comfortable you know people
always say things like well this hasn't
1000 thread count okay the thread count
apparently doesn't mean anything that's
just talking about the density of the
threads within a certain amounts of
space but what you do is you drive past
the gas station la they have a sheet set
until States a thousand thread count you
buy it and it's just actually like a
plastic tarp boland branch sheets are
the best quality sheets there are three
ex-presidents that sleep on them I sleep
on them as well they are fantastic and
the most comfortable sheets I have ever
owned I've encouraged my parents to get
them as well bull and branch calm today
go use the promo code Ben and you get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets plus
free shipping when you use that promo
code bed instead of sheets like 200
bucks there which is significantly less
than the cost for a real luxury brand
and boehm branch is in VA luxury brand
you get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets 50 bucks plus free shipping right
now at bull and branch combi oll and
branch com use that promo code bends
that they know that we sent you and you
get that fifty dollar discount off your
first set of sheets plus the free
shipping okay so big news last night the
gore such thing we can wait till later
to discuss but it's not huge news
because we knew all week today we're
going to confirm justice Gorsuch big win
for president Trump he fulfills a
campaign promise big win for Mitch
McConnell who fulfills a quazy campaign
promise it is a big thing I don't think
it's a huge thing as some people make it
out to me because i don't think the
Supreme Court is this huge a thing as
some people make it out to be I've said
that in the past I will continue to say
that but it is big that Scalia seat is
maintained
for originalism as opposed to being
converted over to left is an activist
seat as a would have under Hillary
Clinton so I got that one totally wrong
during the election cycle i said i
thought that Trump would appoint
somebody who is not conservative or at
the very least Mitch McConnell would not
Ram Trump's pick through over the over
the filibuster and obviously I was wrong
so good for Trump good for Mitch
McConnell that's great stuff but the big
news obviously is that we are now
involved in a war in Syria how much are
we involved not particularly much last
night about would have been about six
o'clock pacific time we get the news
that the United States has launched
50-plus soon as 59 Tomahawk missiles
from the Mediterranean Sea to a Syrian
base an air base that was apparently the
source of the gas attacks that happened
earlier this week on Syrian civilians
that Trump saw and that made him very
very upset here's a lit of the footage
of the strike launching it's pretty cool
stuff and and then the impact
pretty market they they were struggling
to claim some ground they they knock out
be useful to the air base there are six
Syrian Air makers it did not propose the
ability to go out
that is nothing to do nothing and it was
market contrast between President Obama
who after a Syrian gas attack in 2013 he
basically SAT around and did nothing
gathered tried to blame Congress and
then finally hand it over controlled the
whole situation to the Russians but it
has raised a number of really important
and interesting questions the first
question I think is was the strike
worthwhile was it something that was
worthwhile and again I go back to what I
just had a few minutes ago how
worthwhile the strike was going to
depend on what comes next so in 1998
al-qaeda targeted the the US embassies
in Tanzania and Kenya and killed
hundreds of people and Bill Clinton's
response was to shoot off a missile at a
chemical weapons factory supposedly in
Sudan Hannah camel in the ass and that
was basically the end of it then
obviously not only had no impact it
after was counterproductive it convinced
bin Laden that the United States is a
paper tiger we won't can actually do
anything and led to 911 if you just do
these sort of symbolic measures that
aren't followed up on with with any sort
of real cohesive policy then nothing
actually matters here it doesn't it
doesn't matter david french i think
that's that's exactly right in National
Review he says this is the only strike
unless it was extraordinarily an
unusually effective it has little chance
of materially impacting the Assad regime
or the course of the Civil War itself
even if persuades Assad to refrain from
dropping gas bombs he'll doubtless
continue his campaign of mass murder
with barrel bombs cluster bombs the area
bombing and mass executions and as I
just said you know the idea that you can
do a pinprick strike and that's it you
know whether this is effective or not we
just don't know the answer yet because
we don't know what Trump is going to do
yet second question did Trump tick off
his base a certain part of his base
absolutely you know Ann Coulter is very
upset this morning Paul Joseph Watson at
infowars has declared himself off the
Trump train my monopolist says he's
angry with Daddy predictably enough and
and folks like Mike sort of itch are
very angry about this as well and
claiming that anybody who backs Trump on
this thing anybody who thinks this isn't
the worst idea in the world should join
the US military to which I say to two
people like certain events well you seem
very concerned about pizza gay why don't
you go join the DC police force you know
the idea that you are concerned about
something happening in the world and
this is the the rationale you must join
the military if you care about
persecuting a war or prosecuting a war
you must join the police force or the
board
force that you want people to do their
jobs that's silly but the reason that so
many people are upset is because there
are a lot of people who bought into the
original concept of Trump is sort of a
Ron Paul isolationist and what Trump
actually is is an isolationist who if he
gets pissed off fires missiles and
things that's that's all the evidence we
have so far we don't know that he's now
an interventionist we don't know he's
somebody who planned and this is the
great debate what Trump did in Syria
last night was that something where
Trump is actually now going to shift his
entire policy on Syria and pursue
something that's more coherent and
cohesive or is it going to be a
situation where Donald Trump basically
earlier this week said everything is
fine in Syria don't care what Assad does
outside gas is a bunch of people he sees
it on TV he says oh those poor babies
and then he goes and shoots off a bunch
of missiles and then that's it if that's
it that's not going to be good but we
don't know the answer yet you know that
that seems to me the most plausible
solution here is that he doesn't have a
coherent strategy the only reason I say
that is because they're members of the
Defense Department who are already
saying this was one off that this isn't
going to be something that is repeated
and maybe yet to roll out what their
strategy actually is but there's a lot
of confusion so let's start with what
happened before all of this so in 2013
Donald Trump was very militant about not
getting involved in Syria he had a
series of tweets in which he
specifically talked about this he
tweeted we can get those up he said the
president must get congressional
approval before attacking Syria big
mistake if he does not we'll talk about
the constitutionality of this in a
second and then he also tweeted that if
the US attack Syria it'll be a terrible
idea he says of us attack Syria this was
sickened 2013 and hits the wrong targets
killing civilians there will be
worldwide hell did they stay away and
fix broken us and yet now he's involving
himself and then he also tweeted
President Obama do not attack Syria
there is no upside and tremendous
downside Savior powder for another and
more important day so a lot of his
supporters took that seriously and can't
blame them he said during the entire
campaign that we never should be
involved in Syria we should never be
involved in Iran we should never be
involved in a rock we should basically
bring everything home and focus on
building roads in Iowa that's that was
sort of his take and so if you look at a
lot of his supporters they have a reason
to be upset with him today because
obviously that was not his position he
saw something on TV he heard
intelligence reports and then he decided
to act and we'll have to see how you
know we'll have to see how much he ends
up acting
bob Corker senator from Tennessee he
says that he was excited that this
happened because he was wearing Trump
makers make a cheap deal over Russia
atrend Putin and Russia I heard you at
un ambassador nikki Haley criticized
Russia I have not heard president Trump
hold Putin or Russia responsible in any
way he's been far more critical of
Barack Obama on this issue that Vladimir
Putin why yeah I don't know i have seen
by the way in evolution even in Russia
like to see more I looked I'm just being
honest with you I was very concerned in
the beginning that there may be an
attempt to do some cheap deal with
Russia relative to Ukraine and Crimea in
Syria and I don't think there's any
chance of that now I think the president
is the longer reason office the more yes
people coming into chain from other
countries I think that he's developing a
body of knowledge and experience that
will keep anything like that from
occurring and he'll have an opportunity
to see firsthand right now so we'll
finally going to sat we'll find out you
know Putin is is getting very militant
over Syria is this a one-off where Trump
backs down in the future that's possible
to we just don't know what's going to
happen but you can see the flip happened
in real time so earlier this week
tillerson said that Assad could stay in
power then he added that no he's saying
after that gas attack that Russia was
complicit or incompetent in preventing
the Syria gas attack there's information
that Russian agents were on the ground
as they were organizing the Syrian gas
attack he also is now saying that there
are steps under way to remove Assad
altogether which is precisely 180
degrees polar opposite of what he said
earlier this week asad's role in the
future is uncertain clearly and with
acts that he has taken it would seem
that there would be no role for him to
govern the Syrian people and what sets
of the United States prepared
the process by which side would leave is
something that I think requires an
international community effort both to
first defeat Isis within Syria to
stabilize the Syrian country to avoid
further Civil War and then to work
collectively with our partners around
the world through a political process
that would lead to leaving it will you
and Trez no wings down there I mean but
that obviously is a flip in position I
want to talk about all these various
positions but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at legacy box
so it may come as a bit of a surprise to
those of you who know me in this podcast
I am NOT the most sentimental human
being I once forgot my own birthday my
dad though he's a total staff yays manly
and he's my hero but he's a SAP he cried
at the end of Terminator yes really
terminator my mom has always said that
if the house is on fire or underwater or
falling into the San Andreas Fault my
dad would probably be inside the house
trying to save every box of family
photos and every film he could find now
we have legacy box we don't have to
worry about my dad burning or drowning
or falling into the abyss with an arm
full of boxes trying to save all the
family memories it couldn't be easier
you just send your old pictures films
video tapes to legacy box they put them
on a DVD or a thumb drive and that saves
them forever makes it convenient they're
preserved they're ready to watch the
ready to reshare and relive if you're
sentimental which I'm not mostly legacy
box calm / been make sure you do that
you get that forty percent discount on
your order yeah my kids are the best by
the way and legacy box calm again use
that / betta get that forty percent
discount on your order this legacy box
calm so I spend great service something
i really recommend for you and your
family and use that / pens that they
know that we sent you as well okay so
there are really a few different
positions that are emerging on Trump all
we know about Trump is that Trump was
deeply affected in an emotional way that
what happened in Syria so here is what
Trump said after speaking on last night
after the missile attack my fellow
Americans on Tuesday Syrian dictator
Bashar al-assad launched a horrible
chemical weapons attack
on innocent civilians using a deadly
nerve agent Assad choked out the lives
of helpless men women and children it
was a slow and brutal death for so many
even beautiful babies were cruelly
murdered in this very barbaric attack no
child of God should ever suffer such
horror tonight i ordered a targeted
military strike on the airfield in
syrian from where the chemical attack
was launched it is in this vital
national security interest of the United
States to prevent and deter the spread
and use of deadly chemical weapons there
can be no dispute that Syria used banned
chemical weapons violated its
obligations under the Chemical Weapons
Convention and ignored the urging of the
UN Security Council not the right there
this is there is a very new to this if
you're a trump follower and from spent
the entire his entire campaign ripping
on George W Bush saying that george w
bush was a warmonger if you recall what
was george w bush's excuse for going
into iraq it was use of chemical weapons
by saddam hussein on his own people the
possibility of future use of weapons of
mass destruction on Americans and others
across the world holding UN sanctions
against all of this and that's exactly
the same template that Trump is using
here so people have a right to be upset
with Trump if they were against the Iraq
war and now they say well what happened
to the Trump that we knew and loved here
the fact is that isolationism runs up
against reality not only because you see
nasty pictures on TV but because it
turns out that there are nasty forces in
the world from around Russia who are
interested in maximizing their own power
at the expense of us power and that's
really where America's interest lies
here not in the human rights violations
which are terrible but exist all over
the world it really lies in the idea
that
strengthened Russia that has an impact
in broadening the sphere of influence
for Iran and four and four places like
need places like Lebanon and Syria and
Assad that when you do all of this your
heightening the chance of war against
America's allies war against citizens of
the west and terrorism against citizens
of the west and Assad has been complicit
in that all of that said basically there
are three solutions three possible
things that can be done here and we'll
talk about all of them but for that
you're gonna have to go over today lee
weyer calm and subscribe right now eight
dollars a month gets you a subscription
over at daily wire.com right now if you
get a subscription then you can watch
the rest of this show live plus key part
of the mailbag which is happening right
now you don't get to be part of the
mailbag and have your questions answered
unless you go to daily wire calm right
now and subscribe also you get to watch
Clavin show live and be part of
Clayton's mailbag as well plus I promise
there are more goodies coming up for
members in the very near future and if
you become an annual member you get a
kind as a free signed copy of michael
moses reason to vote democrat a
comprehensive guide a masterwork of
political thought about leftism it is
the most thorough book on democratic
thought ever Kwazii pen so pick that up
by becoming an annual subscriber over at
daily wire calm or if you just want to
listen later at itunes and soundcloud
then go over there and check it out and
make sure that you leave us a review
itunes we always appreciate it we are
the most popular conservative podcast in
America